I've known her a long time.
Please welcome, she's here in person, Natasha Lyonne!
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Thank you.
Oh my God, I'm so excited!
Hi, guys.
I was like, "Is she in person?
Is she in person?"
I'm in person.
"Please tell me it's not a Zoom and it's in person."
Zoom is over.
I mean, feel like one of the last hard hangs I had,
before the world changed, was with you.
Yes.
We hung hard.
Walking the streets of downtown New York,
having deep conversations.
And yet, we met when we were, I mean,
in the words of Patti Smith, just kids.
Just kids.
We did a film together in, was it 1996?
I think so.
It may have even been '95, but it was '96.
You were just, you were like my, you know, still,
but I was maybe like, 15 or something,
I think you were like 20.
So to me, you were just the coolest girl in the world.
You were just ultimate rebel.
And then we played half sisters.
Yes.
And, I remember
that the first time I met you,
that was the first time this happened.
You hear about a lot.
Now people even say it to me.
First time, 'cause I seen you on that big screen.
In my mind you were like, a hundred feet tall,
and then this little person came out and,
you came out and you were all, we like, you hugged me
and we were shooting a scene in a funeral home
where everybody was saying, "Enjoy yourself,
it's later than you think."
And you were like, "Hello!"
And I was like, "Oh my God, she's little like me."
It's so funny.
Yeah, it's true.
I think one of the number one comments I hear from people
is, "Oh, you're so short."
(crowd laughs)
(Natasha laughs)
And I'm like, "I guess I am."
The other one people love is, they're always like,
"Wow, you're much better looking in person."
I get that all all the time.
Is that a compliment?
I don't think it is.
I can't tell.
But I think they mean it as that.
They mean well.
It's a icebreaker.
But it's also a confidence breaker.
It's also like, "You photograph terribly,
congratulations on your chosen profession."
Yeah. (laughs)
And everything, all your choices are wrong.
But, your hair is the best hair on planet Earth.
Come on.
(applause)
I don't know if you can really tell,
but I have a mullet right now.
Oh my God.
I feel like the last time I saw you, I got up in it too.
It's the best hair in the world.
Does it make you happy?
Some days.
You know.
Oh, come on.
I love it.
I have really good hair days.
Marcel Dagenais, who does the hair on Russian Doll,
he really, he was the one that really said to me,
"No, we're not styling.
You're wearing it, we're gonna own the natural texture.
We're gonna, you know, keep it really red, heavy bang."
And I think I was so scared, you know,
of almost being myself, I think.
And it was such a weird process.
The warmth, the positivity and the response of Russian Doll,
the more I leaned into sort of, my natural, true self
and got away from this idea of pulling it straight.
And I don't mean for fun or for fashion, but I mean,
as an, you know, an alternate persona or something,
this idea that I had to be a way that I was not.
And it really, really helped me, I think.
Well, I think when you,
(applause)
also play a character which I heard you wanna do Pesci,
is that true?
Oh yeah, I always love the boys.
I see Pesci in Good Fellas, I'm like, "He stole my part."
You know?
Would you ever play him in a movie?
If it came up, I would.
I think it would be scary to do, but I would do it anyway.
You as Joe Pesci needs to happen.
Okay, I think.
I like that everybody almost applauded and they were,
"We're not sure."
(both laugh)
And I appreciate that honesty from you guys
'cause I don't know that we're sure either.
You are everything.
There's nothing you can't do.
You as Pesci I just think needs to happen.
Or his daughter, but I want you as Pesci.
Thank you, finally.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
I'm so glad.
You know, as you guys know, I'm here promoting
my Pesci biopic, and I-
(Drew laughs)
And I did it with no hair and makeup.
I said, "Come as you are." And I just moved through
all the beats of his life and, you know,
you'll see the film and tell me what you think.
I have a working title.
Yeah, what's that?
Pesci.
Pesci, boom, it's done.
That's it.
It's done.
(upbeat music)